- [Narrator:] Eight months after winning the title,
the Rams are nowhere to be found.
And now, Carrie Underwood.
- ♪♪♪ Waitin' all night for morning time. ♪♪♪
- Oh, what happened?
- I went into the bathroom to Zac Yak, and there was a tiger in there.
- What?!
- It's just Who Dey.
- Look away.
If you've seen one hangover, you've seen 'em all.
- Has anyone seen Allen Robinson?
I think you saved him from bears last night?
- How long have we been out? And whose records are these?!
- We need to get back into contention before it's too late.
- I'll catch up with you later.
- Found Allen!
- That's Cooper Kupp. You're looking for a different receiver.
- I have other receivers?
- How much could possibly happen during one party?
- [Matthew Stafford:] F--k them pics.
- You guys lost to something called Cooper Rush?
- You did first.
- Y'all, I think I know how to fix this.
I wanna go for two.
- You have 19, Coach.
- Don't worry, guys. I found a few easy games!
- Where's the last place anyone would expect to find Allen?
- What the hell, man?!
- Is that Allen?
- You piece of—
-I tend to think of myself as a one-man Zac Pack.
And then we drafted Burrow, and there were two of us in the Zac Pack.
Um, and then we lost to y'all, in that big ol' game.
We were like-
-Stop, coach.
It's played out.